Conny you have a PhD in cognitive
psychology correct okay how did you get
involved in doing a book on
screenwriting Paul and I sat together at
a on a committee in 2010 I think or
maybe 11 and he asked me what does
constructionist psychology say about why
people get bored at movies or whatever
he asked these questions that made me
kind of rethink first of all his pulse
ideas about construction of psychology
and my education in understanding the
brain processes that are that he's
really describing he's sort of umbrella
terming constructionist psychology when
it's actually the neuroscience of
perceptual processes and cognitive
processes that are involved in watching
a movie how does our upbringing
determine what movies were attracted to
that would be part of your experience
based what you are attracted to but the
truth is that being human you are
attracted to story so the bottom line is
that movies are hugely successful
because humans are designed for
storytelling it's the way that the brain
actually develops the auditory cortex is
the first functioning perceptual process
happens in utero so way before birth
we're listening to what our world is is
doing around us we don't actually ever
see until we're born but long before
birth we've established safety we've
established humor we've
established you know pleasant versus
unpleasant sounds so as a human being we
we function around story so what forms
people's individual differences are what
happens to them through their life it
does not always predict as Paul was
saying people are feisty individuals
they refuse to be compartmentalized
based on oh you had a lower-income
upbringing and so you're going to
romanticize wealthy people or stories or
vice versa it it doesn't ever ever play
out that smoothly for most people there
is an individual element of attraction
which is an entirely different cognitive
process but the u-19 theme and what we
tried to focus on when we marry these
diverse fields of neuroscience and
screenwriting
was this idea that people have a
similarity in their thirst for
storytelling
so the interleaving of cognitive
processes with plot the interweaving of
perceptual processes with lighting and
shadow and surprise elements in a film
are what we tried to weave into each of
the chapters in a way that gives the
hopeful screenwriter information about
the similarities in his audience that
everybody's eyes transduce light the in
the same exact fashion but what they
have previously seen is what they are
going to perceive in your movie we often
hear about screenwriters taking acting
classes learning to direct figuring at
all facets
behind the camera in front of the camera
how often do you see a screenwriter
focus on their internal make up their
own pathology their own strengths
whatever
I don't know screenwriters I know
cognitive psychologists and I would have
to say that anybody no matter what their
field might be though if the focus does
not involve some self-examination that
you're gonna miss your mark that
understanding how others are going to
respond requires a certain introspection
of how you would respond in that
situation so screenwriters may take
acting classes to understand the art I
would argue that screenwriters need to
take psychology courses to understand
how their response is going to respond
to two sequences or the challenges or
two characters I think understanding how
a human brain integrates perceptual
information with their cognitive
experience so their memories their hopes
their fears is every bit as vital as
understanding how someone may act or
present a character so you worked on the
book for five years
well the I would say the book was an
unspoken seed five years prior to its
publication what actually happened was
Paul and I had fun we were supposed to
be you know serving our College by going
to these committee meetings and instead
we would pass notes like we were kids in
school he would ask questions about
perceptual processes and I would I just
kept saying yes and giving Paul answer
and you know how sometimes
synchronicities are beautiful things at
that exact moment in time
Chapman offered its first co-teaching
award and when the email arrived I read
it and I thought dayum
somebody's been listening in on our
conversations and so we drafted a
proposal which was quite a bit of work
you have to design it for collapse two
courses into one and you have to design
the background literature the syllabi
you know put forth a proposed course
well we we did that and we won we were
the first ever co-teaching award at
Chapman University and we called the
course cinema and the brain and and we
taught together which you've met Paul so
that was hard for me to get a word in
edgewise but we learned how to just play
off of each other and the students loved
it it was a huge success
maybe because Paul showed a lot of movie
clips and so there wasn't a lot of
lecture to listen to but despite
themselves they picked up quite a bit of
basic kind of 101 neuroscience so the
parts of the brain that are involved
when you are seeing or listening and the
parts of the brain that interact when
you have an emotional response a fear
response or or a humorous response and
how the audience is constantly engaged
if the writer or the film switches it up
at a fast enough pace our brains are
pretty quick instruments to play and the
real gift of a good movie is that it you
is that knowledge of when to give the
viewer that emotional pause when they
when they've had too much to process and
how to give that downtime at the same
time keeping them actively engaged so
our first class was such a hit that
despite kind of upsetting the
administration a little bit we were
granted second viewing earth you know
another time to do it and over the
process of that Paul is part of the
United film visual artist I believe
that's the acronym and he was going to
host Chapman who's going to host their
annual conference and so Paul and I were
invited to do what we were doing in
front of the classes for one of their
panels so during that presentation we a
book editor someone from the publishing
houses was there and wanted us to sign
to produce the book so it kind of
dovetailed from what we were doing
mostly having fun is what we've always
done Paula
neither Paula I take anything very
seriously but the experience was I think
I opening not just for me but for you
know the two or three dozen students who
actually went through the class
certainly for administrative Department
wise to see how blended two very
distinct feels actually are so that was
that was what started the book he talked
about switching up cognitive processes
are there certain movies that seem to do
that throughout the two-hour span that
you're really going from one emotion to
the next back and forth sure there are
lots of movies that fast forward your
emotions most of your Jack Reacher
you know solved the crime stay out of
danger are moving at a very quick pace
those movies tend not to involve much
humor or much regret those movies tend
to be based on fear and anticipation so
they keep kind of a higher heart rate
going while you're watching the movies
that are more psychological or involved
the aspect of reflection thinking about
your memories so I got them 500 days or
50 first dates those kinds of movies
that display people portray people that
have lost memory or not forming memories
properly are very engaging real
successful in the box office more
engaging for an audience who may not be
you know a hero or a daredevil or that
kind of a person maybe can watch those
but have a lingering appreciation for
someone whose mind is not working
exactly the way theirs is so lots of
movies come at different cognitive
processes and in forming a story around
not working cognitive processes some
kind of brain injury that has changed
that person you get a lot of fascination
from the viewers perspective because
everybody relates to forgetting at some
time or another everybody's had a
forgetful experience what is it like to
not be able to form a memory so that you
live in a forgotten State those are some
interesting psychological brain
processes that have been presented and
done well in the theaters one of the
aspects that we point out in science of
screenwriting is how skilled a
screenwriter
build in the contrast of emotions so
there's been some studies done and
researchers have used eye trackers in
audiences such that they can tell where
the audience's eyes are focused on the
screen during which kinds of movies and
because we can measure things like how
long the eyes stay on the character and
how often the eyes move off the
character we can translate those eye
movements into attentional factors and
we now understand that timing is
critical so an viewer can take about
three minutes of tension of that kind of
bond fighting with the shark or whatever
that is and then there needs to be a
break or the eyes are gonna saccade you
can't take too much tension so we need a
relief so if you'll notice in the Bond
movies it's really brief it's about a
minute and a half where it's death
murder kill kind of you know tension and
then there's a segue whether that means
that there's a further away shot a long
distance shot or a scan to the boat
that's coming to the rescue or whatever
interruption in order to give the nerves
the the brain processes that are
building tension in that watcher a break
and it it has to be at least at you know
at 30 60 90 second break so the scan
away before you can re-engage in a tight
emotional situation so we know those
processes are happening in daily life
and that when people go to a movie they
and anticipate experiencing deeper
tension more dramatic exchanges but in
order to maintain their attention you
still have to give those interactive
breaks so that there's a release and
then a reengagement in the tension and
conflict in the science of screenwriting
what's your favorite chapter or maybe a
chapter that was most challenging that
you felt very proud of I I think my
favorite chapter is chapter one because
we got to give kind of the overview of
the dance we were going to try to do for
the potential screenwriter or anyone
really who's interested in why movies
are so fascinating why human beings will
go into a dark place with dozens of
total strangers and sit quietly for
hours and that behavior alone is you
know worth a good thorough psychological
investigation so in Chapter one I think
we had a lot of fun building up what we
were going to do in the rest of the book
but I like the chapter that's on the
creative stages of the screenwriter
that's a chapter that involved quite a
bit of research in studying how the
creative process itself plays out in in
any artist in any creative act but in
screenwriting the importance of the
story itself so you had asked Paul a
question about yes or no if you focus on
the audience would that make your screen
write your screenplay a success my
answer would be a flat-out no flat-out
no you you must have the story the story
is what will make your screen play a
success the ability to pace your story
to weave your story to tell your story
in a way that's
spectable even playful with the human
brain that's going to be processing it
that will give your story the the
attraction and the further success but
without the story you can play people
all you want it's you know if you don't
have something to tell them they're
there no reason to engage and in the
chapter on the creative processes the
stages of creativity I got to do quite a
bit of research on what we know about
creativity creativity is considered the
ultimate cognitive process so we do all
these things in our brains right we we
pay attention we perceive all of our
different sensory activities happen in
the brain so you don't see with your
eyes you see with your occipital lobe
you don't hear with your ears you hear
with your auditory cortex so all of
these amazing things happen in the brain
but they happen in parallel processing
simultaneous imal taneous lee so you're
hearing and seeing while you're thinking
about what you're hearing and seeing
while you're remembering what you've
seen and heard while you're predicting
what make so our brains are these
beautiful orchestrations of simultaneous
processes and creativity emerges from
that unique totally individual no two
brains do anything exactly alike so I
think that's my favorite chapter it was
a lot of fun to explore what helps
creativity what hinders creativity and
what the screenwriter can use to get
over slumps you know used to break
through blocks so that was my favorite I
think
thinking of your favorite films are you
able to look at it from another
perspective and see why see the science
behind why you like certain films
sometimes rarely I'm a devotee of
stories I love going to movies and I
don't pretend to be a scientist I'm just
a movie watcher in there there I can
train myself you know to take like Paul
does take Clips sequences and then I can
take apart pieces of movie but if I'm
given an opportunity to be told the
story I take it storytelling is it's the
human gift
there are as far as we know no other
vertebrate animals that engage in
fantasy that engage in storytelling
it makes us uniquely human and from my
perspective it's this connection to
language which as I was saying is begun
before birth we we listened in utero for
that voice that is closest to us so the
person carrying us is the most important
voice that we hear and I think that I
don't know it's magic to me and I'm a
scientist I'm all about data but it is
magic to me that we communicate at all
that we get each other even you know
vaguely and that we do it so
effortlessly and so successfully the
gift of language the gift of
storytelling is what I've taught for
decades and it's still just a magical
mystery tour it's amazing how we don't
run out of language we don't run out of
stories yeah your boy meets girl or you
know these kind
of repetitive plots but each and every
movie about boy beats girl captures us
as an audience holds us we are as if
we've never seen the whole scenario
before that's a good movie right the the
ones that don't make it are the ones
that have not added enough of that
individual creativity to the
storytelling so even language if it's
not our native language we can still
relate you know how people love seeing
foreign films is there something
different about that or that's a great
question and I love talking about when
so as if you were deaf as if you did not
have auditory processing and so you were
fault and following along closed caption
you're reading the subtitles you still
get all the emotion that's portrayed
visually but there's a lot of data that
suggests the sound not just the language
but including the language but the
background music the tension sounds the
relaxing sounds the auditory cues that a
screenwriter adds to their film to
create that emotional mood when those
are missing the movie is much more
intellectual process and much less of a
you know full-body emotional I'm in this
story so watching foreign films takes a
different mindset when you go to watch a
foreign film you and you know you're
going to be watching the the subtitles
to get the dialogue if you're a hearing
person and you can still have the
background cues to what's going on it's
much more successful for people who have
auditory disabilities there it's movie
watching is an entirely different
experience what do you think it'd be
helpful for screenwriters when they look
at the science behind
and story I think it's profoundly
helpful for a screenwriter to recognize
the physiological processes that their
audience is experiencing to have at
least a minimal understanding of the
visual and the auditory information is
being received the same by everybody's
eyes and ears work the same way but once
that information is transduced into
neural impulses in the brain that is
where the screenwriter needs to
understand that every person in there is
working from a different schema an
organized set of their experiences
building up their own individual
expectations here is where the
screenwriter can capitalize on general
experiences so in this day and age
almost everybody has seen a movie or has
watched video clips so there's a certain
amount of experience that exists at a
general level what can they do in their
screenwriting to make that unique to
make that individual to make their story
stand out from the expected that I think
understanding the interleaving of memory
and language and emotions with the
physical processes so what the audience
is seeing or hearing is key to the way
we dedicate our book to the success of
future storytellers
I think storytelling will take on really
fascinating new perspectives when
screenwriters
begin to consider the brain processes of
the audience that they are telling the
story to